a number of people asked me what is a
beautiful deleveraging well first let me
start with what is the deleveraging
sometimes there's too much debt burden
which also means that somebody's holding
too many debt assets and they're not
going to get paid and so what is
necessary is to bring those things down
in relation to incomes and so that's a
deleveraging and what is a beautifully
leveraging a beautiful deleveraging is
when that happens in a spread out way
over a period of time and in a balanced
way now spread out let me give you an
example if you can't pay all your debts
maybe you can pay 70 or 80 percent of
those debts and you spread that over a
period of time and for those who are not
getting those debt payments then that
um shifts their burden over a period of
time and then there are two ways of
bringing down those debts paying less or
having the Central Bank print money
which produces some inflation pressures
and when they do that if they print a
little bit of money and then you have
the restructuring they can balance each
other and make it a smoother and less
disruptive and that is a beautiful
deleveraging